derrière ses grilles xavier dupont de
ligonnès at il pu rester tapi dans
l'ombre
les enquêteurs ont voulu tirer les
choses au clair suite au signalement
d'un témoin disant avoir peut-être
reconnu le fugitif le plus recherché de
france
d'après les informations du journal du
dimanche la police judiciaire de nantes
et l'office central pour la répression
des violences aux personnes ont
perquisitionné l'abbaye de ce village le
18 mai dernier sans succès non loin de
là cette habitante a vu toute la scène
on a vu de trois gendarmes qui étaient
dehors je pense d'autres quêtes à
l'intérieur mais c'est tout quoi c'est
comme ça et puis on a pensé qu'il y
avait des travaux nous n'établit travaux
terminés sur l'abbaye
xavier dupont les blast ça vous a
surpris qui le cherche dans un lieu
comme ça à côté de chez vous non ça m'a
pas surpris ce sont des gens très pieux
dupont de ligonnès était le cas et sa
femme est en général bien s'élancer
chose à casseneuil qui viennent quoique
et circle l'abbaye et le siège d'un
mouvement catholique traditionaliste
attachés au rite ancien selon certains
fidèles que nous avons rencontré
impossible que xavier dupont de ligonnès
ait pu s'y cacher sans être repéré en
1989 pourtant paul touvier anciens
collaborateurs du régime de vichy est
alors en fuite
il y avait séjourné avant d'être arrêté
à nice la dernière trace de xavier
dupont de ligonnès dans l'indre remonte
à 2011 les enquêteurs ont établi